Hey, what's up guys welcome back you might remember last week we tried making Coke Rockets using propane
We saw videos all over the internet claiming that you could mix propane and coke and getting them to blast off like a rocket
However, when we tried that we found that at the epic fail, oh boy
now when I discovered the propane does absolutely nothing it hit me and maybe something got lost in translation
Maybe the experiment is supposed to be done with butane
so the purpose of our experiment today it to see if we can get these coke bottle rockets blasting off using butane
So in preparation for this experiment. I went down to the local hardware store. I cleaned them out of butane
I bought everything they had now butane comes in canisters like this. It has very similar properties to propane
It's under pressure
And it's extreme fire hazard
Now getting this out in Liquid form is a lot easier than the propane all you have to do is pop off the cap turn
The canister upside down find a way to depress the nozzle and have some kind of a container to collect the liquid underneath
Alright, so we've got our butane. We've got our bottle of coke
Here's the basic idea of how the experiments going to work
First, we'll need to pour a little coke out of our coke bottle so the liquid levels off just below the lettering on Coca they're going
To take our caster of butane turn it upside down and squirt the butane into the bottle of coke
Until the liquid level rises to the top to label at that point
It's just a matter of loosely holding the bottle in our hands turning it upside down and watching the Magic happen
Here we go it's ready. Let's do this coke and butane  rocket see if it works
whoa
Bottle tipping over is like a slight delay, and then boom gone like a rocket because that's what it is Coke Rocket
That's the reaction I was looking for
It cleaned our bottle right out and now we can use this empty container to pour more butane
We can actually fill this thing all the way up and store it with the cap on because we found
Like propane we can store butane the coke bottle as well
interesting observation guys I just went through two of these canisters of butane filling up this coke bottle we made it to the top and
Label there which is about three hundred fifty milliliters and that right there cost about ten dollars you're looking at ten Dollars of Liquid butane
guys crazy
All right guys. It's time for test number two this time
I poured out a little less liquid you through the top of the coke lines up with the topic later here weird of course will
Be obtained into the coke bottle it forms a layer about an inch high flip some coke bottle over the feet that takes off any
more vigorously
That's cold stuff
It froze my glove
Interesting that when you release the pressure it all spews out everywhere like a fountain and that is very cold liquid you see that quickly
We've already lost like a third of our container
Wow, it's amazing. How much of that liquid disappears? I just pour it in there slowly
the blows bubbles
There's some pretty quickly
There we go. That's a good amount of liquid way there
Sure for that
Here we go
There's quite a bit of power to those things
They're not nearly as explosive as it's not they're going to be but they definitely work success
So this one has a little bit less butane, and it will keep that makes you different
Cool, so by hanging on to it a little bit longer actually got a little resistance. I like that one the best
this is the whole reason this works guys when you flip the coke bottle over the butane rises to the top because it's lighter than
the Coke itself
And because it's trapped us know where to go it rapidly builds pressure and forces the coke out of the mouth of the bottle creating
Thrust making it shoot off like a rocket
Now I do have to say that because our coke is cold it might be delaying the reaction if we had warm soda it would
probably happen a lot faster and
possibly make the bottle explode but saying that you wouldn't want to hold on to them for too long with your hands either because if
They did rub your it
There's a good chance the plastic will pray out and take your skin with it
Number this next experiment something I've always want to try [is] the way [we] want to eat waffles
I've seen videos where people hold the bottles on the edge of their fingertips and let it fall off where it catches itself and shoots
Off from there, I'd like to see if we can get that to work for us as [well]
A
Little bit of a delayed reaction wasn't it like hit the ground and shot over sideways, not exactly what I was going for that
Actually seems a little more powerful
Attempt number two here we go
Man, I think of explosively, but I like hit the ground and social
I can't get it to go like right off my hand with [this] front. So that was pretty cool
You can see it tipping you can see the butane mixing with the coke rising to the top
But [then] it actually gets [to] [prom] before we get that explosive reaction it takes off
So in order to get them to shoot up
You'd almost have to hit it straight on and have to be perfect now because we're using butane for this experiment
It has a characteristic that liquid nitrogen doesn't liquid nitrogen is not fly well the butane is so for our grand finale
Let's do something that you definitely shouldn't try at home
Let's plate it off and see if we can get our coke rocket to blast off in play
Firing all right let's get it. Thanks here. We go 00
last of the work
That burned a lot faster than I thought I was going through
It was kind of hot like holy in the bottle I was worried about the tip burning
There's the flip you can see the flames
Descend like a waterfall and then the bottle just disappear. There's a whole column of fire
That's crazy imagine if they sprayed all at you. I probably heard a lot
I think I've squirts my fingers a little bit. I can smell burning human hair, but that was awesome
That was an epic way to go out in style
pink
Right on guys so here's what we learned from our experiments today
We started off with the knowledge that propane and coke don't do anything
So we wanted to try using butane if you can get that to cause reactions dead
Although the reactions weren't nearly as powerful as I'm used to seeing with liquid nitrogen and water
They still were powerful enough to make a coke rocket. It's a viable idea we also discovered that one canister of Butane
Oh Philip. Coke bottle about halfway and give you enough for two coke bottle shots and at five dollars per canister
I'm not really sure whether or not that's actually worth it next we tried skipping the coke bottle off of our fingertips [it] found that
There wasn't enough reaction time it actually fell down and hit the ground first
Then jetted off like a rocket one can make contact
I'm not exactly sure the reason for the delay
But it might have been because our coke was a little bit colder we discovered
you can fill up a coke bottle with Mutane cap it off and the strength of the bottle is enough to contain the fluid but
As we unscrew the cap and release the pressure we saw the liquid begin to boil and a lot of it disappear
For our final experiment and grand finale we showed
That unlike liquid nitrogen containing extremely clowns
So we lit off the gas turned our bottle upside down and watch the rocket blast off in a flaming fiery fashion
And there we have it based on this set of experiments. I'd say the coke and butane rocket is a success
Thanks for joining me for this experiment guys. I'll be looking for in the next video. Talk to you then
Yeah, I look great
Hey guys, thanks for watching and remember. I'm giving away prizes now on every new video
all you have to do to qualify is subscribe to my channel ring the bell and
Selectively notified when my next videos get released the secret link to my giveaways will be pinned in the comments for the first 12 hour
If you like what I'm doing
So your support right now by giving this video a big thumbs up and share with a friend. I love you back
I'll see you next time